DETACHED FROM HOW THIS COUNTRY
FEELS ABOUT THE SITUATION.
LET'S BRING IN JENNIFER GRIFFEN
NOW.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO WHAT WE
JUST HEARD FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> I'M TRYING TO SORT THROUGH MY
REACTION BUT THE FIRST THING I
WOULD SAY IS THAT, WHACK
CONTINUES TO BE AMAZING TO ME IS
THAT EVERY TIME THE PRESIDENT
SPEAKS, HE SETS A DEADLINE THAT
THEN THE MILITARY HAS TO
SCRAMBLE TO ADJUST TO MEET.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT TAKES TOSS EITHER
EVACUATE PEOPLE, THE BUILDUP,
THE TIME NEEDED, THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE THAT HE HAS PROMISED THAT
HE WAS GOING TO GET OUT.
HE MAKES STATEMENTS LIKE ALL
U.S. CITIZENS WILL BE EVACUATED
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
RIGHT NOW, THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T EVEN KNOW HOW MANY
AMERICANS ARE IN AFGHANISTAN.
WHEN I HEAR THE PRESIDENT
TALKING ABOUT THESE SO-CALLED
OVER THE HORIZON CAPABILITIES,
THERE ARE NO OVER THE HORIZON
CAPABILITIES.
THOSE ARE EMPTY WORDS.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY BASIS IN THE
REGION WHERE YOU CAN PLACE
DRONES, WHERE YOU HAVE
INTELLIGENCE OFFICERS.
WE NOW HAVE NO PART ERS IN ON
THE GROUND IN AFGHANISTAN, OTHER
THAN THE TALIBAN, AND HOW'S THAT
GOING TO WORK IN TERMS OF OVER
THE HORIZON CAPABILITIES?
THE ISIS THREAT IS REAL.
EVERY DAY THAT US TROOPS ARE ON
THE GROUND AT THE KABUL AIRPORT
THEY ARE A TARGET, SITTING DUCKS
THEY KNOW THAT.
IT IS EXTRAORDINARY THAT THEY
HAVE GOTTEN 21,000 PEOPLE OUT IN
THE LAST 24 HOURS, UP TO 70,000,
BUT THE PEOPLE THEY HAVEN'T
GOTTEN OUT ARE THE PEOPLE THEY
PROMISED TO GET OUT, AMERICANS,
AS WELL AS THOSE WHO WERE
TRANSLATEERS WHO ARE CARRYING IN
THEIR HOMES WHO WE'RE GETTING
VIDEOS OF THEIR FAMILIES MEMBERS
BEING KILLED AS THE TALIBAN
CLOSES IN ON THEM AND THE
CALLOUSNESS OF THESE SFRAMS THE
WHITE HOUSE WHEN THE PRESIDENT
READS THOSE STATEMENTS AND
STARTS WITH A DOMESTIC AGENDA
AND THEN SAYS OH, BY THE WAY,
HERE'S WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
AFGHANISTAN TODAY, IT IS SO
DETACHED FROM REALITY.
BUT THE REALITY IS THE AMERICAN
TROOPS WHO ARE ON THE GROUND AT
THE AIRPORT, WHO ARE HAVING TO
TURN BACK PEOPLE AT THE AIRPORT,
WHO ARE HAVING TO LIFT BABIES
AND WOMEN OVER THE WALLS, WHO
ARE BREAKING RULES, AT TIMES, TO
GET PEOPLE IN WHO ARE IN NEED
BECAUSE THE RULES BEING SENT
FROM WASHINGTON OF WHO CAN COME
THROUGH THE AIRPORT AND THE
TALIBAN BLOCKING AND NOW WE HAVE
TO ASK MOTHER MAY I TO THE
TALIBAN IF WE CAN GET AMERICAN
CITIZENS THROUGH THEIR CHECK
POINTS.
IT'S SO APPALLING.
AND IT DIDN'T HAVE TO BE THIS
WAY.
THIS IS -- PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK
THIS DECISION TO GO TO ZERO.
HE ANNOUNCED A DATE,
SEPTEMBER 11TH, OF ALL DAYS, AS
A WITHDRAW DATE.
THE MILITARY PULLS OUT, THEY
HAVE TO GO BACK IN 11 DAYS, THEN
EXPECTED TO MOVE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN IN A MATTER OF A
WEEK WITH.
IT'S ONLY BEEN A WEEK SINCE THE
TALIBAN TOOK OVER AND ALREADY WE
REPORTED EARLIER TODAY, THE
MILITARY'S HAVING TO PACK UP
BECAUSE, ONCE AGAIN, THE
PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN AN ARBITRARY
DEADLINE, AUGUST 31ST.
WHY AUGUST 31ST?
AND THE TALIBAN NOW HAS, YOU
KNOW, WHEN THEY HEAR THE
PRESIDENT TALK ABOUT A DEADLINE,
THEN OF COURSE THEY'RE GOING TO
MAKE HIM HOLD TO THAT.
IT'S SO BAFFLING.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING
ARE THE AFGANS WHO ARE BEING
LEFT BEHIND, THE WOMEN AND THE
CHILDREN HOP WON'T BE ABLE TO GO
TO SCHOOL, AND THOSE POOR
AMERICAN TROOPS WHO ARE DOING
THE BEST THEY CAN RIGHT NOW,
BEING GIVEN AN IMPOSSIBLE TASK.
I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE THE TRAUMA
THAT THEY WILL -- THEY ARE
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW AND THAT
THEY WILL BE SUFFERING FROM WHEN
THEY GET HOME.
AND THEN THERE'S THE VETERANS
BACK HOME WHO FEEL SO AWFUL WHO
ARE GETTING WHAT THAT MESSAGE IS
AND E-MAILS FROM THEIR
TRANSLATEERS WHO SACRIFICED
THEIR LIVES FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE, MANY OF WHOM, THOUSANDS
OF WHOM, WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN OUT.
WE DID NOT KEEP OUR PROMISE AND
IT IS A NATIONAL SHAME.
>> WELL SAID JENNIFER.
AND WE HAVE A QUESTION FROM GREG
GUTFELD, SO PLEASE STICK AROUND.
>> YEAH.
ABOUT LIKE THIS MASS WEAPONS
TRANSFER, I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT IF THIS STUFF IS ACTUALLY
ACCURATE BECAUSE IT'S SO
UNBELIEVABLE.
I MEAN, WAS THIS ON PURPOSES?
WAS THIS ACCIDENTAL?
WAS THIS PART OF A DEAL THAT WE
WEREN'T AWARE OF THAT, WHEN WE
LEAVE, WE WERE GOING TO LEAVE
ALL OF THIS GREAT EQUIPMENT.
SORE IS THE EQUIPMENT NOT
WORKABLE?
HAS IT BEEN DISABLED?
LIKE THERE'S ALL THESE -- I
CAN'T -- I GUESS I CAN'T BELIEVE
THE STORY.
>> SO, GREG, I THINK YOU HAVE TO
SEPARATE IT INTO TWO PARTS.
FIRST OF ALL WHEN THE U.S.
MILITARY PULLED OUT AND LEFT
BAGRAM AIR BASE AND LEFT A FULLY
ARMED AFGAN NATIONAL ARMY OF UP
TO 300,000 TROOPS THEY HAD TO
LEAVE THEM WITH WEAPONS.
WE HAD SPENT $85 BILLION OVER
THE YEARS, THERE WAS BOUND TO BE
STOCK PILES OF WEAPONS, YOU
COULDN'T TAKE ALL THE WEAPONS
WITH YOU AND EXPECT THE AFGAN
NATIONAL ARMY TO FIGHT THE
TALIBAN.
THEY DIDN'T EXPECT THE AFGAN
ARMY TO FOLD SO QUICKLY.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS SOME OF THE
MORE ADVANCED EQUIPMENT, THE
HELICOPTERS AND A PATCHIES, THEY
PULLED -- THAT WAS PART OF THE
RETRO GRADE WHEN THEY LEFT
BAGRAM.
AGAIN, THE EXPECTATION WAS THE
AFGAN NATIONAL ARMY WOULD STAND
AND WOULD CONTINUE TO FIGHT OFF
THE TALIBAN EVEN IF IT WERE JUST
A FEW MONTHS.
SO THEY WERE KIND OF CAUGHT
BETWEEN WHAT DO YOU DO.
OTHERWISE, IF YOU REALLY KNEW
THE TALIBAN WERE GOING TO TAKE
OVER IN 11 DAYS, YOU WOULD HAVE
BLOWN UP THE WEAPONS DEPOSE.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS THEY WANTED
TO GIVE THE AFGAN NATIONAL ARMY
A CHANCE, THE REAL PROBLEM WAS
WHEN PRESIDENT GHANI FLED, THAT
ARMY FELL APART.
>> ALL RIGHT, WE HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION HERE FROM DANA.
>> GENERAL, I'M CURIOUS ABOUT
WHAT YOU HEAR INTERNALLY, IF YOU
CAN SPEAK TO IT, AT THE
PENTAGON, IF THERE'S FRUSTRATION
ABOUT BEING -- GIVEN A MISSION
THAT THEY ARE NOT BEING GIVEN
THE RESOURCES IN ORDER TO
COMPLETE, AND WHAT ALSO, YOU
KNOW, AND WHEN A PRESIDENT
SPEAKS, IT'S TO ALL THESE
DIFFERENT AUDIENCES, THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, OUR ALLIES, OUR
ADVERSARIES BUT VERY
SPECIFICALLY IN A SITUATION LIKE
THIS OUR TROOPS.
AND I'M JUST ASKING WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING IN TERMS OF REACTION ON
THAT END.
>> IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE I
DIDN'T ACTUALLY HEAR PRESIDENT
BIDEN SPEAKING TO OUR TROOPS.
THERE ALLEYS ALWAYS THAT CATCH
PHRASE AT THE END GOD BLESS OUR
TROOPS BUT I DIDN'T HEAR HIM
ADDRESSING OUR TROOPS, I DIDN'T
HEAR HIM ADDRESSING OUR VETERANS
OR ANY SORT OF EMPATHY
WHATSOEVER.
THE MILITARY, AS YOU KNOW, THEY
PA LIEU SMARTLY WHEN THEY'RE
GIVEN AN ORDER, GET AS MUCH DONE
AS THEY POSSIBLY CAN AS QUICKLY
AS THEY CAN.
I SPOKE TO SOME FORMER SENIOR
LEADERS HERE AT THE PENTAGON WHO
HAVE SERVED IN AFGHANISTAN AND I
SPOKE TO ONE LAST NIGHT WHO
WOULD HAVE BEEN IN THIS POSITION
AND WOULD HAVE HAD TO OVERSEE
THIS WITHDRAW IF HE WERE STILL
IN COMMAND.
AND I ASKED, WHAT IS IT -- IS
THERE ANYTHING THE MILITARY'S
DOING WRONG FROM HIS POINT OF
VIEW THAT HE WOULD HAVE DONE
DIFFERENTLY AND YOU CAN QUIBBLE
ABOUT A FEW MINOR THINGS,
THERE'S BEEN THE DEBATE ABOUT
WHETHER YOU SHOULD HAVE PULLED
OUT OF BAGRAM FIRST AND THE WAY
IT WAS EXPLAINED TO ME IS WE HAD
A CHOICE, AND THIS GOES BACK TO
THE DEBATING OF THE PLAN WHEN
THE MILITARY WAS GIVEN THE ORDER
BASICALLY TO BEGIN PLANNING TO
WITHDRAW BACK IN APRIL, AND THAT
WAS, DO YOU STAY AT BAGRAM, YOU
ARE A GOING TO NEED A BIG FORCE
PROTECTION TO DO THAT, ARE YOU
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET THOSE
CIVILIANS AND SIVS TO BACK RAG,
THERE'S NOT AS MUCH
INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND THERE.
OR DO YOU HOPE THE AFGAN
GOVERNMENT'S GOING TO HOLD AND
YOU KNOW WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR OR
TWO YOU MIGHT HAVE TO WITHDRAW
CITIZENS FROM KABUL
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT.
THEY OPTED FOR THAT.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S PROS AND CONS
TO BOTH.
BUT I THINK THE -- I SEE THEY
ARE WORKING UNDER A VERY
DIFFICULT, ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
TIME LINE, PARTICULARLY KNOWING
THAT THERE IS AN ISIS THREAT.
NOW, REMEMBER, WHAT ISN'T
EXPLAINED ALL THE TIME IS THAT
ISIS HATES THE TALIBAN AS MUCH
AS THEY HATE US.
ISIS WOULD LOVE TO EMBARRASS THE
TALIBAN, WOULD LOVE TO FIRE ON
THE AIRPORT SO AMERICANS HAD TO
PULL OUT UNDER FIRE.
THERE ARE A LOT HAVE DIFFERENT
FACTORS THERE.
IT IS AN EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH THEY ARE
DOING THIS.
THEY KNEW THAT GOING INTO IT,
BUT THE BLYTHE MANNER WHICH THE
PRESIDENT SEEMS TO HAVE GIVEN
THE ORDER TO WITHDRAW, IT JUST
BOGGLES THE MIND THAT THIS WAS
ALL KNOWN AND THIS WAS ALL
BRIEFED TO THE PRESIDENT.
I KNOW THERE WERE HEATED
DISCUSSIONS IN THE SITUATION
ROOM ABOUT THE HUMANITARIAN
CATASTROPHE THAT WOULD FOLLOW
GOING TO ZERO.
AND IN AFGHANISTAN.
BUT ONCE THE PRESIDENT TOOK THAT
DECISION, THE MILITARY HAD TO DO
THE BEST THEY COULD TO ENSURE
THAT THERE WERE NO TROOP
CASUALTIES AND NOW TO GET AS
MANY PEOPLE OUT AS THEY CAN.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, TIME IS
RUNNING OUT.
>> JEN, PLEASE STAY WITH US.
I WANT TO PLAY SOME SOUND AND
THEN GO TO YOU, ABOUT GENERAL
KEANE FROM EARLIER.
>> THE TROOPS ARE THERE TO
ACCEPT RISK TO GET AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND AFGAN PARTNERS OUT.
THEY ARE FULLY AWARE OF THAT
MISSION.
I THINK WE HAVE LEADERS HERE WHO
ARE ABSOLUTELY RISK A VERSE.
THEY FEAR CASUALTY.
THEY FEAR SOMEBODY GETTING HURT
SERIOUSLY.
THEY'RE RINGING THEIR HANDS OVER
THIS.
THERE'S A LACK OF SPINE I THINK
BEING SHOWN HERE.
>> THIS IS BIDEN'S CALCULATION
AS I SEE IT.
HE IS AFRAID TO GO PAST THAT
DEADLINE BECAUSE ANYTHING GOES
AFTER THAT POINT.
YOU COULD HAVE A LIVE FIRE FIGHT
AT THE AIRPORT, HAVE GUYS
SURROUNDED.
WHO KNOWS WHAT COULD HAPPEN.
YOU COULD HAVE MASSIVE
CASUALTIES, CIVILIAN CASUALTIES,
HE WOULD THEN HAVE TO SEND IN
MORE MEN TO THE AIRPORT AND
THAT'S A TOTAL MESS.
HE WOULD RATHER LEAVE WHEN THE
TALIBAN TELLS HIM TO ON THE
31ST, JUST SO HE DOESN'T HAVE TO
RISK THAT SITUATION HAPPENING.
BUT BY DOING THAT, HE STRANDS
THOUSANDS OF OUR PEOPLE BEYOND
THE WIRE.
>> AMERICANS, OUR AFGAN ALLIES
AND OUR FRIENDS, JENNIFER, TO
THAT POINT, THE FRUSTRATION I'VE
HEARD FROM SO MANY VETERANS,
SPECIAL OPS, TALKING TO THEM,
EVEN TALKING TO A MAN WHO WAS --
FLEW A HELICOPTER INTO THE I
DRINK VALLEY FIRST CALVARY AIR
MOBILE, SCREAMING ABOUT LET US
GO IN AND DO WHAT WE DO.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TRAINED FOR.
WE DON'T LEAVE PEOPLE BEHIND.
THAT'S THE FRUSTRATION.
.
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN DOESN'T GET
THAT.
>> WELL THE PROBLEM IS, AFTER 20
YEARS OF WAR, THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE LEFT BEHIND.
SO WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO,
WILLY-NILLY SEND EVERY VETERAN,
1.2 MILLION OR 1.6 MILLION WHO
HAVE SERVED SINCE 9/11 BACK IN
TO GET THEIR TRANSLATEERS?
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOME SORT OF
ORGANIZED EFFORT.
THE PENTAGON TRIED TO ORGANIZE
THAT EFFORT BUT THERE HAVE BEEN
VARIOUS ROAD BLOCKS HAVING TO
WORK WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT,
HAVING TO MAKE SURE BIO METRICS
WERE DONE AND THAT YOU KNEW WHO
YOU WERE BRINGING OUT.
THERE ARE CONSTRAINTS.
I THINK BACK TO THE POINT THAT
GENERAL JACK KEANE MADE, IT IS
CLEAR THIS PRESIDENT AND ANY
PRESIDENT BEFORE HIM DOES NOT
WANT ANOTHER BLACK HAWK DOWN,
THEY DO NOT WANT AMERICAN TROOPS
GETTING SURROUNDED BY A CROWD
AND GETTING DRAGGED THROUGH THE
STREETS OF KABUL.
IT IS UNDERSTANDABLE THAT IT IS
THE U.S. MILITARY'S GOAL TO GET
OUT WITHOUT HAVING ANY U.S.
CASUALTIES AND TO NOT HAVE TO
LEAVE UNDER FIRE WITH, YOU KNOW,
IN ANY FURTHER EMBARRASSMENT
THAN WHAT WE'VE SEEN SO FAR.
SO GIVEN THOSE CONSTRAINTS,
THERE IS A REASON THAT U.S.
TROOPS, FOR THE MOST PART, ARE
STAYING BEHIND THE WIRE AT THE
AIRPORT, AND HEROICALLY HAVE
GOTTEN 70,000 PEOPLE OUT IN A
MATTER OF WEEKS.
BUT, THAT BEING SAID, THE
HEARTACHE BEING FELT BY THE
VETERANS AND THOSE WHO WORKED
WITH TRANSLATORS WHO ARE SENDING
IN THESE CALLS FOR HELP, IT'S
MORE THAN ANY OF US CAN BEAR.
BUT YOU CAN ALSO UNDERSTAND WHEN
YOU'RE THE PRESIDENT, COMMANDER
IN CHIEF, YOU DON'T WANT TO JUST
SEND YOUR FORCES OUT WILLY-NILLY
IN THE STREETS OF KABUL WITH A
HOSTILE FORCE IN CHARGE OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> JEN, TO THAT POINT, A GOOD
ONE ABOUT THE VETERANS, AND I
TALKED TO A GUY, SPECIAL FORCES,
FORMALLY SPECIAL FORCES THERE,
HE'S BEEN WORKING AROUND THE
CLOCK DOING FUNDRAISING TRYING
TO GET THE INTERPRETERS HERE.
HE SAID THE PLEADING HE IS
GETTING FROM THEM IS ALMOST
BREAKING ME.
I WANT TO PLAY THIS, THIS IS
CONGRESSMAN MICHAEL WALLS FROM
FLORIDA SPEAKING EARLIER TODAY
AT THE HOUSE STEPS ABOUT THIS
VERY ISSUE AND I THINK BACK TO
WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT NOT ADDRESSING THEM.
AND IT SEEMS VERY DISCONNECTED
BUT TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT HE
SAID.
>> WHEN FUTURE AMERICAN SOLDIERS
HAVE TO GO BACK IN TO DEAL WITH
THE PROBLEM AND DEAL WITH THE
ENCOMPETENCE OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION, HOW MANY ARE
GOING TO DIE?
NOW.
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
FIGHT THEIR WAY THROUGH OUR OWN
EQUIPMENT.
OUR OWN DAM EQUIPMENT.
>> SO JEN I JUST WANT TO MAYBE
GET YOUR TAKE ON THAT BECAUSE
THERE ARE SEVERAL MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE THAT SERVED AND THE ANGER
IS PALPABLE, YOU HAD JASON CEO A
DEMOCRAT SAYING THE SAME THING.
>> THERE IS BIPARTISAN OUTRAGE
FROM ANYBODY WHO EVER SERVED IN
AFGHANISTAN.
YOU HEARD THAT.
YOU HEARD THE EMOTION FROM
CONGRESSMAN WALLED.
THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE.
AND WHAT IS PARTICULARLY
EGREGIOUS IS THIS EXACT SAME
THING HAPPENED IN IN 2011 IN
IRAQ.
VICE-PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN OVERSAW
THIS WITHDRAW AND THREE YEARS
LATER THE U.S. MILITARY HAD TO
GO IN TO FIGHT ISIS.
IT IS VERY HARD TO IMAGINE
HOW -- WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
WHEN THE TALIBAN BEGIN ALLOWING
BASES TO BE SET UP INSIDE
AFGHANISTAN.
I MEAN, ONCE AGAIN, THESE OVER
THE HORIZON CAPABILITIES, THAT
REQUIRES SOME INTELLIGENCE.
THAT REQUIRES BASING.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT IN THAT
REGION.
SO THAT IS A -- YOU KNOW, THAT
IS A MYTH.
AND IT'S JUST -- WE HAVEN'T
TALKED ENOUGH ABOUT PAKISTAN AND
HOW VERY DANGEROUS NUCLEAR
PAKISTAN IS NEXT DOOR AND YOU
NOW HAVE THE TALIBAN ON THE
DOORSTEP WITH AN ALLIED PARTNER
IN NUCLEAR PAKISTAN.
THE AMOUNT OF PROLIFERATION, AND
ALSO, LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW
TERRORISTS AROUND THE WORLD ARE
WATCHING THIS AND HOW IS THIS
DIFFERENT FROM THE 1989 WITHDRAW
OF THE SOVIETS THAT INSPIRED AL
QAEDA THAT THEN LED TO 9/11?
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT, OF
COURSE, EVERYBODY WOULD LOVE TO
SEE NOT ANOTHER AMERICAN SOLDIER
BE SENT -- OR MARINE SENT TO
AFGHANISTAN.
NOBODY WANTS TO STAY THERE A
MINUTE LONGER.
HOWEVER, THERE WAS A WAY TO KEEP
A LID ON THINGS WITH A VERY
SMALL FOOTPRINT.
WE SHOULD HAVE CHANGED THE
NARRATIVE LONG AGO.
AND I FAULT THE MEDIA FOR THIS.
THIS WAS NOT A FOREVER WAR, THIS
WAS NOT AMERICA'S LONGEST WAR.
THIS WAS AN INTELLIGENCE OUTPOST
STRATEGIC AS SET THAT WE NEEDED
SEVERAL THOUSAND AMERICAN TROOPS
TO GUARD IN ORDER TO SAFEGUARD
OUR HOMELAND.
>> JENNIFER, THANKS SO MUCH.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THOSE
WORDS, AND